[Música]
muchas veces me han hecho muchas
preguntas cuando me encontraba en una
feria donde me habían invitado fui con
mis robots con algunas tecnologías que
había creado
y en ese momento se dieron a la cita
público en general estudiantes jóvenes y
todos se acercaban y me hacían las
mismas preguntas de siempre que
habitualmente hace que es lo que tienes
aquí para qué sirve
cuánto cuesta qué proyectos tienes a
futuro las mismas preguntas de siempre
hasta que en un momento se acerca una
niña entre los 4 a 6 años y me hace una
pregunta y me dice
señor cómo puedo hacer para que la mente
de mi gatito entre en uno de esos robots
esa pregunta no la podía responder era
muy compleja era una pregunta muy
inocente
la niña estaba triste porque tenía
problemas con su mascota tuve que
pensarlo muy bien y le dije no sé hecho
aún pero si tú te pones a investigar oa
estudiar un día lo vas a lograr
se han preguntado cuál es su propósito
en su vida qué es sueños tenían cuando
eran niños
yo tenía varios porque cuando somos
niños creemos que todo es posible
cuando entré a la escuela yo era uno de
los niños más tímidos y callados que
había y tenía miedo no poder ser lo que
un día realmente quería lograr hasta que
conocí a dos de mis profesores que me
enseñaron que era un muchacho creativo
un muchacho con mucha imaginación y
sobre todo mucha pasión al que se ha
posicionado les dije ellos me dijieron a
pasearles aquella persona que siente
entusiasmo por algo
así que me dan retos de materializar
como maquetas volcanes explosivos
maquetas de dinosaurio donde ellos
reunía a todos los estudiantes para que
me ayudaran a crear estas maquetas
prehistóricas y en esta etapa también me
encanta aprender a dibujar
y la esencia de todo esto era la
curiosidad
ya llegamos a hacer más adolescentes
jóvenes opto por disciplinas que me
ayuden a enriquecer la creatividad la
imaginación en el deporte optó por una
disciplina que es el capo era es una
expresión corporal del cuerpo donde
aprendes artes marciales danza defensa
personal
y también en lo artístico la música que
me encanta tocar un instrumento aprender
a cantar un poco lo cual me ayudó a
hacer de un muchacho tímido y callado a
un muchacho extrovertido algo así como
una actualización de mi propio software
y la verdad me gusta hacer mucho así el
día de hoy
ya estás joven te toca entrar a la
universidad y siempre nos hacemos la
pregunta que voy a estudiar yo sabía lo
que tenía que hacer pero no sabía que
iba a estudiar preguntaba a mis
familiares a los que estaban cerca no
tenía muchos familiares profesionales la
verdad y solo se nos ocurriría decir de
que deben estudiar paleontología porque
me gustaban los dinosaurios o debería
ser arquitecto porque me gusta dibujar e
incluso mi hermano que le gustaba el
fútbol merecía debería ser futbolista
sabía que no era nada de lo que yo
quería hacer sabía que mi mente estaba
crear crear así que para encontrarme
decidido trabajar primero trabajar unos
años encontrando a mí mismo me involucro
con los autos electrónicos
en dónde
aprendo un poco de mecánica aprendo
software habiendo electrónica y la
verdad me enamoro de la tecnología sé
que es lo mío
y sabía que si iba a seguir con esto me
iba a ayudar a encontrar mi propósito
y la verdad decido estudiar una carrera
en ingeniería ingeniería electrónica la
cual sabía que me iba a ayudar a ser lo
que realmente quería ser
y la verdad los últimos siete años de mi
vida han empezado a ser diferentes por
esta decisión que tomaron el de poder
crear tecnología llega el primer
semestre en la universidad yo entro con
mucho entusiasmo de poder crear algo mío
algo propio algo que pueda ser autónomo
o cumplir una tarea o resolver algún
problema
se lanza un concurso de robótica en el
cual yo quiero totalmente entusiasmado
de poder participar
pero había una un problema yo no sabía
ser un robot y era una pregunta que nos
cuestionábamos todos los que queríamos
aprender de que era un robot es
específicamente así que decidió indagar
por mi propia cuenta me meto a los
seminarios me meto los talleres que
lamentablemente por falta de
organización no llegaban a concluirse y
no llegaba a aprender nada en el momento
así que decido buscar por mi propia
cuenta encuentra un amigo que sabía del
tema e incluso él decide enseñarme sin
ninguna condición yo ofrezco pagarle y
después de varias pruebas aprendizaje
luego construir mi primer robot aunque
no era gran cosa pero era algo propio
algo mío que lo hice por primera vez e
incluso casi logró ganar en la
competencia un pequeño robot seguidor de
línea que simplemente el objeto deberá
encontrarse que usted
llegar a optimizar esto me demoro
alrededor de 3 a 3 meses pero a
diferencia de hoy lo puedo hacer en un
día o quizás un par de horas
y en esta etapa de mi vida me doy cuenta
que para crear crear tecnología se
requiere de mucha creatividad mucha
imaginación y sobre todo de mucha
inversión
ya cuando empiezo a crear más robots de
este tipo
siempre llegaba a mi casa con una nueva
creación pero mi familia creía que
estaba perdiendo el tiempo creía que
estaba haciendo juguetes creía que
estaba invirtiendo mal mi dinero y era
duro la verdad y así que tenía que
mostrar el lado bueno de todo esto
siempre me ha gustado participar en las
ferias de ciencia robóticas sin ninguna
condición simplemente con el hecho de
poder demostrar lo que he podido lograr
o hacer
me encontraba en una de estas ferias
probando uno de mis prototipos
un poco distraído hasta donde se acercan
dos ingenieros y empiezan a cuestionar
lo que tenía y uno de ellos le dice mira
el otro responde sí pero estos son los
son juguetes
yo me quedé escuchando y inmediatamente
responde el otro si pueden serlo pero
por algo se empieza
en ese momento sabía que estaba haciendo
lo correcto uno no nace siendo grande
uno puede hacerse en el camino y crear
grandes cosas debido a esto quiero
involucrarme más y empezó a crear
robótica educativa competitiva
entretenimiento así como los robots
guard bots para que podamos competir la
única regla de esto era destrozar sé
nada más
pero pero también empiezo a cuestionarme
y quiero crear cosas más divertidas
tales así como un animatronic por
ejemplo un robot que pueda completar ya
sus funciones la mínima crónica es la
combinación de poder unir circuitos
integrados mecanismos robóticos para
mimetizar el movimiento de un ser vivo o
en este caso
que pueda cumplir ciertas tareas tales
así como ser un chat bot responder
preguntas y una de esas es mi robot
chapit que el objetivo de este robot es
de que según díaz un chat web para que
puedas responder las preguntas que les
decía un principio
también nosotros queremos crear grandes
cosas soñamos los que estudiamos
ingeniería y muchas veces tales así
queremos algo grande así como una
armadura de iron y con ustedes mi
armadura de iron
[Música]
[Aplausos]
crear y crear crear es divertido verdad
bueno para mí está bien es mi manera de
auto motivarme día a día para seguir
creando pero de qué sirve crear y crear
si no tiene un sentido si no tiene un
propósito tienes las herramientas pero
de qué serviría así que decido
adentrarme un poco más y empezar a crear
a querer mejorar mis habilidades físicas
así como levantar objetos pesados o no
sentir fatiga muscular cuando sea más
adulto decido involucrarme con los
exoesqueletos como verán son estructuras
estructuras externas a diferencia de
nosotros que tenemos un lindo esqueleto
interna que nos sostiene que nos ayuda a
poder estar así de pie un exoesqueleto
es un armazón que te recubre
externamente un claro ejemplo es el
escarabajo hércules este insecto pequeño
es capaz de levantar 850 veces su mismo
peso
gracias a la ayuda de su exoesqueleto
y yo tenía que ver cómo realizar este
tipo de proyectos con el material que
existía en nuestro contexto era complejo
y la verdad era más complejo de lo que
me había planteado pero nunca hay que
darse por vencido
en la actualidad tengo alrededor de 6
exoesqueletos de miembros superiores y
miembros inferiores queriendo cumplir
este objetivo pero ahora tiene un
objetivo más sólido
es el de poder usar este tipo de
tecnologías para poder ayudar a las
personas a rehabilitarse o incluso
aquellas personas que han perdido una
movilidad están en silla de ruedas
puedan volver un día volver a caminar
ese es el objetivo que tenemos con los
exoesqueletos
había una brecha que quería cerrar
entre la capacidad y la discapacidad y
es el de poder crear soluciones que
ayudan a mejorar la vida de las personas
me dado cuenta que en el mundo todos los
países resuelven sus problemas yo
encontré uno grande acá en nuestro país
hay un grupo de personas que viven en el
silencio y en el anonimato esperando
tener algún día una oportunidad para
mejorar su calidad de vida las prótesis
se han vuelto otro de mis retos cuando
me enteré que acá en bolivia se estaban
empezando a equipar los primeros
centros de impresión 3d yo me acerqué
con el objetivo de poder comprar una
prótesis impresa en 3d para poder
modificar y poder ayudar a una persona
pero no cuando me acerco ahí no me
gustaban los modelos en primer lugar
eran muy caros así que decido crear mis
propias prótesis
y llegar a poder hacer esto creo que me
demoro alrededor de tres años entre
estar investigando y poder equipar me
también para poder hacer esto después de
varios intentos llega el primer paciente
la hora de la verdad un paciente que
había tenido el problema en los
antebrazos que no podía y ya no tenía
las ganas pero después de varias pruebas
de error varios diseños horas de trabajo
logramos resolver nuestro primer
proyecto en prótesis de brazos de
antebrazos creíamos que a un principio
este tipo de soluciones ayudaría a una
persona a verse simétricamente bien
estéticamente bien y que pueda cumplir
ciertas tareas como levantar un vaso
poder volver a vivir
pero me equivoqué estas prótesis llegan
a ser mas polifuncionales cuando pasó el
tiempo nos enteramos que este
paciente que tuvimos podría alzar una
galleta pequeña podría abrir la puerta
del taxi podía abrir la puerta del
minibús e incluso podía pagar su tarjeta
del teleférico sin la ayuda de un
usuario aprendimos mucho de estas
personas aprendimos hablar de lo que son
capaces y la verdad yo creía que cuando
íbamos a trabajar en a futuro con otras
personas los casos iban a ser similares
como estos pero me equivoqué totalmente
cuando las personas empezaron a enterar
de este tipo de soluciones empezaron a
venir personas con problemas en los
dedos en las manos malformación
congénita
vettel de brazo brazo incluso
desarticulación total pérdida del brazo
se había vuelto una responsabilidad
grande porque las personas tenían una
esperanza al ver este tipo de proyectos
y era el momento de pensar y decidir si
si iba a seguir en este camino o
simplemente volver a lo que
habitualmente hacía crear lo que estaba
haciendo para divertirme
hasta que me acordé de una frase de una
de las personas que admiro édgar
villarreal dijo
jamás abandones tus sueños más aún si
éstos cambiarán o mejorarán la vida de
las personas
bastaron estas palabras para saber que
estaba haciendo lo correcto y tenía que
seguir creando
y con la ayuda de la creatividad de la
imaginación ya tienen un propósito y
mucha pasión logramos resolver problemas
de brazos antebrazos manos dedos
ayudando a este tipo de personas
empezamos a personalizar las prótesis
para nuestros niños para que puedan
identificarse con sus superhéroes
tal y como uno de nuestros pacientes que
es feliz y se cree un superhéroe pero
también tenemos niños grandes que les
gusta la tecnología y sueñan con tener
una vida mejor tales es uno de nuestros
pacientes o vídeo que vino con el primer
problema de hombro después de varios
prototipos él quería irse con el
prototipo a medias el mismo el día de la
prueba
pero después de proveer no ven mucho
amor a lo que hacíamos el que lo hace
como un soldado del invierno de los
avengers
pero también existen personas que
requieren prótesis para trabajar para
conducir e incluso para tocar una
guitarra que es su fuente de vida
i
a todo esto a esta aventura me dado
cuenta que hemos creado soluciones
hemos creado sonrisas
y aprender a ver de qué son capaces
todas estas personas
accidentalmente puede unir dos
disciplinas que a un principio yo creía
que todo iba a ser la tecnología
tecnología para resolver problemas mi
hermano juan carlos que se vio hace
mucho tiempo al exterior
a buscar mejores condiciones de vida
vuelve para estudiar una carrera de
fisioterapia y kinesiología
y cuando yo me encontraba haciendo uno
de mis proyectos en prótesis él me dice
hey yo te podría ayudar a mejorar esto y
la verdad en ningún momento lo había
pensado considerado no me había dado
cuenta que a mi alrededor tenía un gran
aliado que me ayudaría a mejorar me
ayudaría a crear más sonrisas
a todo a toda esta parte de mi vida me
he dado cuenta que
he alcanzado un propósito en la vida el
de poder crear tecnología poder crear
robots crear soluciones y sobre todo
muchas sonrisas la pasión es la clave
para que tu idea sea exitosa la pasión
nos da la fuerza para perseverar en lo
que queremos alcanzar yo los invito a
que usen sus habilidades para mejorar
la vida de las personas
yo decidió usar mi pasión para mejorar
la calidad de vida de estas personas y
la verdad la vida es demasiado corta
como para vivir haciendo algo que no te
gusta
vive tu vida compasión
[Aplausos]